oh getting ready to ring in the New Year
we invite you to go with us from coast
to coast We'll Be Live From The Palms
Resort Casino as 8 news now hosts
countdown to 2023. hosts Michael Yo and
Nikki Novak will take you around to the
best parties across the country and also
show you performances from artists like
country music star Keith Urban
I hesitated with the idea of residencies
because it sounded like being in the
same place night after night after night
after night made me very nervous but
when I saw how the schedule would flow
when I saw the venue the audience is
different every night in Vegas they're
never the same for a guy who loves being
in the moment that's a perfect place for
me
Keith Urban talking about his residency
here in Las Vegas and you can watch Mr
Urban and a whole lot of other
performers right here on New Year's Eve
join Michael and Nikki as they and you
count down to 2023 our party starts at
around nine o'clock with the ball drop
in Times Square and though we should
then we show you the fireworks shows all
across the country and right here on the
glittering Las Vegas strip Nate